on a fait comme si comme si on avait
rien fait
allô est-ce que Paulo Kalia il est là
s'il vous plaît pour Thierry Ardisson
Paul
bonjour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est encore plus beau qu'avant c'est
devenu magnifique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici il y a combien de temps que tu
habites ici mais si ça fait 10 ans déjà
c'était quoi ce lieu avant avant c'était
une entreprise donc il est à l'époque de
la à l'époque de la guerre je crois que
ça servait pour mettre un peu les frigo
de viande ça peut commencer
après tout était déplacé là-bas et
l'écran arrivé il y avait d'ailleurs
même les wagons qui arrivait directement
ici dans la dans l'immeuble il y avait
des il y a des rails même dans les
couloirs et donc la marchandise est
arrivé sur des sur des petits pas wagons
directement ici c'est pour ça que les
les appartements sont en face des
appartements mais les lieux sont assez
fermés
c'est pour ça que quand tu regardes
l'immeuble de l'extérieur ça fait comme
un bruit donc il y a plusieurs à des
endroits il y a trois quatre cinq
fenêtres et moi il y a des endroits
en plus parce que quand on est chez toi
et qu'on regarde par la fenêtre on va
voir la fenêtre attends je vais t'ouvrir
peut-être ce mec qui se trouve la
fenêtre ouais c'est étonnant ce qu'on
voit par la fenêtre parce que le seul
coup c'est une complètement une autre
voilà ça c'était drôle cette ambiance
très baroque les groupes et le chantier
un peu de Paris de cet endroit un peu je
suis en train de construire la nouvelle
station de métro qui s'appelle météo
qui est mon voisin qui s'appelle
Jean-Michel Jean-Michel 3 qui lui a son
travail d'artiste j'étais un travail
conceptuel et pendant 5 ans il a fait
tous les démarches d'aller en Pologne
pour récupérer locomotive qui servit je
crois pendant la guerre tu vas pour il
va t'expliquer mieux tu vois
c'est drôle
c'est toi
c'est plus que rigolo
de Pologne c'est ça
va être transporté les gens dans les
comptes c'est ça c'est une guerre
allemande
affectée au 32 potes aussi
tu veux que je te dise un truc le plus
impressionnant c'est l'odeur
c'est pour ça que en fait il y a 7
scénographies et je vous laisse entrer
en premier
le visiteur lui
quand le lieu est ouvert au grand public
commence par sentir par l'odeur c'est
l'odeur et la deuxième chose c'est que
l'endroit étant relativement exigu par
rapport à l'objet on est impressionné
par la dimension de l'objet c'est à dire
qu'on ne si on avait 50 mètres de recul
on serait beaucoup moins impressionné
alors que là on voit la locomotive comme
devait l'avoir les les gens qu'on
mettait dans le train alors ce qui est
troublant aussi dans sur cet objet c'est
que
elle a été construit en économie de
guerre
c'est à dire qu'elle a été étudiée pour
coûter le moins cher possible être la
plus efficace possible
avec la logique de l'industrie allemande
de l'époque
et ils ont créé cette espèce de monstre
puisque en fait un morceau du monstre
voilà alors les les roues ont été
peintes
les bandeaux blancs des roues sont
peints avec de la peinture fluorescente
et c'est important pour moi parce que ça
faisait partie du de la réflexion sur
l'objet sur l'objet de l'histoire
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire avec un objet
de l'histoire
comment faire de cet objet une oeuvre
d'art par une intervention éphémère
puisque la fluorescence disparaît qu'il
ne reste pas de trace et par son
déplacement et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu